I mean take a look politically at you
know what it what's happening in America
what's happening in other Democratic
countries where where the uh the
competing political parties the
competing tribes no longer honor one
another right all you need to do is to
you know go back to the the rate Reagan
uh Reagan Mondale debates from the 80s
and just look look at those videos of
the way they treat one another the
difference between you know what that
kind of politics and the politics we
have today which consists you know of
this constant constant drumbeat of
insult abuse slander dishonoring one
another look it's just like a marriage
if you want a divorce if you want a
civil war then just keep dishonoring the
other person just keep focusing on
everything that's wrong with them and
you'll you'll you'll get your divorce
you'll get your Civil War
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
watching and listening on YouTube
I have today with me Dr yorum hazoni
we're going to talk about
his new book He's written a number of
books we're going to talk about his new
book conservatism rediscovery
and uh I'm very much looking forward to
that he's quite a scholar of
conservative thought political thought
in general and so I hope to learn a lot
today well I have the opportunity to
sift through his knowledge
welcome yorums good to see you hello
Jordan
good to see you
so let's talk about your book why a
rediscovery I think
most people at this point have figured
out that that we're undergoing some kind
of cultural revolution and uh I I think
I think this hit a high point uh two
years ago in 2020 when uh when when
people started getting fired from from
prestigious academic positions and and
media positions for holding you know
regular liberal positions that people
have had had for decades and uh I I
wrote this book in order to try to uh to
make some order in this cultural
revolution uh these woke neo-marxists
are obviously not liberals and it seems
that the the old liberalism doesn't have
the fight and the Firepower to be able
to uh to to uh roll this back and the
question I think everybody needs to be
asking is you know what what kind of a
force would be strong enough to stop it
everybody talks about all the things
that the left is doing wrong and and of
course that's that makes sense but if
we're thinking about opposition into it
the question is what what kind of force
is going to be strong enough to stop it
and I I think to discuss that you have
to go into uh into conservatism how
would you characterize what's happening
on the left
do you think I mean what is what's the
nature of this cultural revolution
it's after World War II I think both in
America and and across Europe uh there
there was a kind of a a consensus which
um I mean all the major part of
political parties all the major cultural
streams uh agreed on a kind of a a
liberal framework and you can call it an
enlightened liberal framework the basic
idea is that uh that what you need to
know about politics is that human beings
are by Nature free and equal that they
take on moral obligations and political
obligations on the basis of consent and
that was assumed to be sufficient in
order to you know to to guide the
political world so there were there were
disagreements within liberalism
Progressive liberalism and and and
libertarianism and Classical liberalism
but the basic framework held for 60 or
70 years and now the I I think the most
important thing to understand is that
that liberalism which you know in a lot
of ways it's very well intentioned it's
very very Noble
um but but it assumes that children when
they're being raised that they don't
they don't need any kind of traditional
guidance they don't need any kind of uh
customary framework guard what people
call guard rails today that are
inherited and are are
consciously inculcated uh by parents by
Churches by by schools the Assumption
was and and I I think for many many
parents still is for two generations the
Assumption was you tell your kids when
they're growing up look whatever makes
you feel good uh whatever fulfills you
whatever it is that that you know that
uh that gives you meaning in life that's
what you should do and the important
thing is to be happy that sounds really
nice but as you know as you know from
from your work and your studies when you
raise kids like that a great many of
them uh simply reach a kind of a a dead
end they whatever makes you feel good
well they don't know what makes them
feel good and uh into that vacuum
steps steps in in a uh this woke Neo
Marxist movement which has answers it
gives people answers and the the
um
uh the surprise is that you know all all
of these mainstream liberals thought
that if you just told kids use your
reason think for yourselves figure it
out for yourselves we trust you that
everybody would sort of come to
something normal but it turns out that
that's not true when you tell all the
young people for two generations just
think for yourselves you know whatever
looks good to you it turns out that a
great many of them are are much more
attracted to Marxism or and some of them
even to Fascism than than to uh the the
the the mainstream liberalism so that
went on for two generations and now it's
collapsed I mean basically 2020 was the
the year that the hegemony of uh the
mainstream liberal ideas came to an end
there's still obviously lots of liberals
running around but in terms of the the
assumptions of the society right right
now we actually have this woke
neo-marxism seeking to impose a new
hegemony and they're frightening close
so it seems to me that you could make a
case that classic liberalism worked
because it was running on stored
cultural capital in some sense is that
when the institutions that you're
speaking about were more or less intact
so that would be Church let's say family
stay stable monogamous heterosexual
marriages and Civic
Society
membership in clubs and that sort of
thing when all that was functioning then
it principle it was possible to treat
people like they were autonomous
reasonable individuals because you had
already laid the groundwork for
something approximating a shared ethos
but as that evaporated because people
became more atomistic and hedonistic
than the shared ethos started to
deteriorate and other idea sets became
more attractive does that seem
approximately correct I I think that's
exactly right I I would just just add
the the loyalty to a to a national
framework to a nation so basically if if
people are raised with loyalties to to
family to a a congregation to to a
community and then to a larger Nation
um then then they know something about
where they are you know that they can
criticize uh they can argue about you
know how are we going to organize these
these loyalties how can we improve
things but exactly exactly as you said
if they don't grow up with those things
if those things are are are no longer
clear because uh because the the
cultural capital as you say is running
down
um the inherent The Inheritance is
basically being spent and once that
inheritance is gone then then there are
no limits there is no framework there's
no common sense I mean what we call
Common Sense is is always the common
sense of a particular uh Nation or
Community or family and once those
things have broken down there is no
common sense and people actually are
willing to consider you know just about
any crazy
evil thing
big government continues to spend
borrowed money inflation continues to
swell dragging down our economy and the
stock market has entered bear territory
so what's your plan are your assets
Diversified I'm Phillip Patrick precious
metal specialist for the Birch gold
group for nearly 20 years we've helped
Americans diversify into gold and we can
help you too did you know you can own
physical gold and silver in a tax
sheltered account we can help you
transfer an IRA or 401K tied to stocks
into an IRA in Gold if you're skeptical
about the trajectory of the economy in
the US dollar then text Jordan to 989898
Birch gold group will send you a free
info kit on securing your savings with
gold with thousands of satisfied
customers five star reviews and an A
plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau we take Precious Metals seriously
text Jordan to 989898
for your free info kit
so I've been I've been thinking a fair
bit about the potential contribution of
of
I would say
clinical and counseling psychologists to
this Mass because
there was a tremendous emphasis probably
throughout the whole hundred year course
of the development say of Clinical
Psychology and clinical Psychiatry on
sanity as something in some real sense
internal to the individual and so
thank you can see that I would say in
its most
stellar
exemplars in the humanist psychologists
of the 1960s and kind of figures that
that would occur in the 1960s that
you were saying and capable of
psychological well-being if you were
well-constituted psychologically
but
I've been thinking more recently that
that's not a very useful model of Sanity
because it downplays
the social embeddedness that
characterizes people who are
psychologically stable and therefore
capable of Happiness if you're stable
you're not anxious you're not
completely ridden with negative emotion
that doesn't necessarily mean you're
happy but if you do a careful analysis
of what people mean when they say they
want to be happy what they really mean
is they don't want to be miserable and
happiness is like the icing on the cake
but they definitely don't want to be
anxious and frustrated and disappointed
and in pain and confused and aimless and
all of that and
so it isn't obvious to me at all that
it's possible to be
psychologically intact in isolation I
think the most potent proof of that is
even
that even hardened criminals anti-social
types fine being in solitary confinement
almost intolerable and so if that's the
case
you might ask well what exactly is
social being doing for us and
if you're married
you have someone who's somewhat
different than you to keep you in check
constantly like married couples are
throwing back and forth information to
each other about how to regulate the
relationship and themselves non-stop
that's pretty much all of what
communication consists of and then
if you have children or your parents
your siblings let's say that immediate
family the same thing is happening is
that people are monitoring one another
and providing each other with feedback
about how to behave and how to think and
then that's nested inside a Civic
community and that's nested inside a
state or a province and then that's
nested inside a country and Sanity seems
to be something like and maybe all of
that's nested inside some religious
presuppositions
it's the harmony between all those
levels that seems to be
essentially
what constitutes sanity rather than
something that's
formally internal like maybe your
internal structure reflects that
external Harmony and that's like in a
fractal manner in a holographic Manner
and that's what sanity constitutes and I
would say that the liberal emphasis on
say self-actualization and as the on the
atomist itself as the center of the
world has
deluded itself into thinking that any of
that's possible without an intact
hierarchy of social structures
surrounding the individual now it seems
to me to be the weakness the fundamental
weakness on the psychological front of
of even of classic liberalism I think
that's exactly right and I I think that
you were already
speaking pretty much to this uh in in
your earlier work when you were telling
you were telling young people look
um you need to find you need to find
your place within some kind of social
hierarchy and uh this is actually the
the extension of your your earlier
argument I mean both both of us are
drawing on on durkheim's Insight that uh
look if you want to know what is it that
leads people to to Suicide then uh it's
anomian what is that right that's the
the the lack of a directional sense a
set of guard rails which comes from
those nests and hierarchies that you're
that you are describing if the
individual now none of this means that
that an individual can't you know if he
or she is unhappy can't look for a
different place in a different hierarchy
but the point is that that wherever they
end up if they're going to be motivated
and directed and feel like their life
has meaning and purpose and direction
it's going to be because they have found
their place in a hierarchy that works
for them and and liberalism simply
doesn't simply doesn't uh touch on on
this Central human need by the way the
marxists are pretty pretty much aware of
this they do think in terms of
hierarchies of course their goal is to
destroy them but at least they can see
them whereas the the Liberals are always
thinking kind of in terms of flat land
that you know by the time you're 18 or
20 then you're equal to everybody and
it's the assumption is that everything's
level but but the truth is nothing is
level there are always hierarchies and
people feel good when they found they
found the right place in in such a
hierarchy by the way that means that
they have something to Aspire to move up
in the hierarchy they've they know they
have some idea of where they're going in
life
yeah well you talked about you just
spoke of guard rails and Direction and
now it seems about right to me I mean
when I worked as a clinician and I was
trying to understand what made for a
good life let's say when I was dealing
with people who were depressed because
well often they didn't have the
necessary guardrails or Direction and
that was part of the reason they were
depressed I mean depression is
complicated there's many reasons for it
but
it does seem to me to be an
incontrovertible truth and I think that
my audiences
have responded very well to this
proposition that almost all the meaning
that you find in your life that isn't
merely a consequence of a narrow end and
short-sighted Hedonism is found in
the service you provide to the people
who are in your
social
Networks
and that would be first of all obviously
your intimate relationship and your
family and then in the hierarchical uh
nesting nested structures that that that
are outside of that if you're fortunate
enough to have them and the guard rails
are that there are codes of behavior
that are necessary to
to abide by
that constitute
adhering to the principles of all those
social relationships and the direction
is
whatever the joint venture that you're
embarking on with others is directed
towards and I don't see that you do have
any
structure or purpose in your life in the
absence of those things I mean if you
strip someone of their let's say
embeddedness within an educational
institution or within a job or a career
you strip them of their family you strip
them of all their civic responsibility
I suppose perhaps they have their
creative Endeavors if they happen to be
creative people but even then
they have to be interacting with other
people to communicate about their
creative Endeavors or to monetize them
and without that there's well there
really is nothing and we also know too
that psych statistical studies of of
language usage have indicated pretty
clearly that
thoughts about yourself are
indistinguishable from negative emotion
that's how heavily tinged they are with
negative emotion as soon as you become
self-conscious as soon as you start
thinking about yourself you're instantly
anxious and miserable they're the same
thing
and so
okay and so then on the Marxist front
because we talked about the collapse of
liberalism the fact that liberalism in
some sense is an empty Concept in the
absence of these underlying practices
and Customs let's say where that they're
actually embodied that you actually act
out they're not conceptual precisely the
marxists I think have an advantage over
the Liberals and maybe this is one of
the things that accounts for the
attractiveness of Marxism to young
people is that the marxists at least
they have an attitude towards guard
rails which is destroy them but they
also provided direction right and the
direction is essentially a revolutionary
Direction it it combines a critique of
of hierarchy concentrating on the idea
that hierarchies are intrinsically
pathological but then it also provides
Direction and group membership and so
that's pretty compelling in the absence
of any structure say
which at least in principle is what
would be offered by the classic liberals
right but notice that you know I mean
this issue goes all the way back to Marx
notice that the uh that the theory is
that that uh hierarchical structures and
uh uh competition between groups always
means that there's going to be
oppression and the goal is always to to
over overthrow the dominant hierarchy
but notice that Marx doesn't answer Marx
doesn't answer the question of what's
going to come after the revolution is it
incredibly vague about it and this
continues to this day which is that the
the the the unspoken truth here is that
these woke neo-marxists are Masters at
creating tight hierarchical structures
that people can fit into that that I
mean that that's that's the reason that
that that people get sucked into this
woke thing they sound so much like
robots and they're they're you know
they're constantly repeating you know
precisely the new new thing that they're
supposed to be saying and the reason for
this is because because the their their
own hierarchical structures that they're
creating are are of the you know the the
tightest and most disciplined kinds so
so I mean there is
um I think you can I think a lot of
people sense this there's a terrible
hypocrisy in in the whole in the whole
woke thing in that the claim is that
they're you know they're they're
bringing Social Justice by overthrowing
existing uh existing social structures
existing hierarchies but they themselves
are imposing precisely the same thing
that they're well worse no no they're
opposing something worse I mean this is
something that's that's very very
striking historically so
so let's take the Marxist position apart
the first
oversimplification is that there is a
hierarchy
instead of a multiplicity of hierarchies
because in any reasonably functioning
modern society there are innumerable
hierarchies and part of the reason that
we can live without being too crushed by
hierarchical difference is because as
you said before you can move from one
hierarchy to another and that might be
something as straightforward as
changing jobs not that that's
particularly easy but it's not
impossible and so if you can't find a
place in one economic structure
microstructure then you can find a place
in another and I think one of the real
antidotes to rigid
uniform
monolithic hierarchy as a provision of
multiple games and I think modern
societies do a very good job of that and
and then
and so the idea that there's one
hierarchy although you could rank order
people by wealth I suppose but the idea
that there's one hierarchy is
preposterous except under Marxist rule
in which case everything does tend to
collapse into a single hierarchy that's
absolutely monolithic and totalitarian
beyond belief and that just happened
time and time again so you have to
presume that there's some fundamental
flaw in the Marxist formulation and
maybe the flaw is something like look
you have to accept
um a moderate amount of hierarchical
structuring and you have to hope it
doesn't get too lopsided so that only a
few have everything and everyone else
has nothing that's a pathological
situation although it's not only a
consequence of say Western economic
structures it's that is a human
Universal that proclivity or or natural
Universal that power law distribution
problem now if you criticize hierarchy
to such a degree that you want to
destroy all of it then all that you do
is instantly produce something
approximating the most tyrannical
hierarchy you can possibly imagine
because you destroy the differentiated
structures exactly what happened in the
Soviet Union in China you destroy all
the intermediary
distributed multiplicities
structures and you replace that with
Tyrant and peasants
that's true but
you know let me push back just just a
little bit because I think I think that
a healthy Society
is one that certainly has a a
competition of uh you know multiple
tribes maybe different religions I think
these things are probably more important
to people people's identities are are
more tied to uh to Regional ethnic
religious groups than they are to you
know to what what job they have and so
what I what I what I meant about you
know when I said that people can change
is that it look it's always possible if
you don't if if you don't like your
nation to move to a different Nation if
you don't like your religion you can
convert to a different religion but the
the bottom line is that uh thing that
big structures macro structures like
um like the the uh the hierarchy that
constitutes uh constitutes a Nation
those are those are the things that are
missing I think from from the liberal
picture of course a healthy nation and
and I would hear I would I would insert
the word conservative is that the the
difference between uh between a uh a
Marxist view of uh the hierarchy the
hierarchical power structures within
nation and a conservative view is that a
conservative says
um look there's always going to be
groups that are more powerful than
others uh that there's no such thing as
no hierarchy there's always going to be
a competition among groups and some
groups are going to be more powerful
than others you know like like like like
the the uh uh the Anglo-Saxon Protestant
uh uh grouping within the United States
for most of its history and so so
they're going to be groups that are more
powerful than others but that doesn't
mean that the most powerful groups have
to oppress the other groups they're in a
in a conservative Society there there's
a an ongoing negotiation
among the different groups you know
there's a jostling in a competition just
like in in just like in family life you
know there's a constant bickering and
jostling among children for you know for
position and even between a husband and
wife the reason husbands and wives
bicker is you know the reason they
squabble is is because there's a
constant you know uh um trying to find a
place where where you feel like you're
being properly honored you feel like
you're being properly respected and in a
uh in a traditional
um conservative Society what's going on
is that you you inherit certain ways of
structuring things and and then you can
you can adjust them you can try to
correct them but the goal of the
conservative Society is to have a
distribution of honors a distribution of
of uh justices you know of of of what
people get and where they get placed
within the society and that distribution
the conservative claim it doesn't always
have to be evil like the marxists say it
doesn't always have to be oppressive you
can have a situation in which the more
powerful groups understand that they
have a responsibility to the weaker
groups and you can argue about exactly
what that is but a a mutual a mutually
beneficial conservative Society is one
in which the the uh different groups get
things out of out of the collaboration
out of the the mutual loyalty it's not
just the strongest things in the we get
crushed but everybody gets things and I
think I think that a lot of what
conservatives are reacting to when they
you know when they see what the marxists
are trying to to build is that you know
you're trying to grab everything for
your group whereas a traditional
conservative society says says know the
the the just balance of honors among the
different groups that's what makes
people feel good that's what makes
people loyal to the system otherwise
there is no loyalty to the system
there's just depression yeah well the
marxists also have the advantage that
I would say of two they have a two-fold
Advantage first of all they can appeal
to envy and they're unbelievably good at
that I mean I think the fundamental
motivating force of Marxism is is envy
and now it'd be it'd be a close race
between that and desire for untrammeled
power but we can certainly start with
envy and it's very easy for people to be
envious of anyone who has more of
anything than they do and one of the
things that I've already been struck by
on the left is the constant
presupposition that if someone has more
than me they got it because they're
using power in oppressive way it's
always the cutoff between the oppressor
and the oppressed is whatever status I
happen to have as a left-wing
intellectual
because I got what I have honestly and
through hard work and diligence but
anybody who has more than me obviously
took it from the people who are lesser
than them
and so that's definitely an appeal to
Envy but there's something underneath
that I think that is more powerful which
is that and this is a criticism that
conservatism is susceptible to is that
hierarchies do tend to degenerate in the
direction of arbitrary power when they
degenerate and every hierarchy is
degenerate to some degree right because
there's a bit of corruption in
everything and so then the marxists can
point to the corruption especially if
they're appealing to young people and
they can say well look at that person in
that position of authority and the awful
things they did that were oppressive and
impro improper obviously everyone who
holds any position of authority is
corrupt in some fundamental way and then
obviously the whole system is corrupt
and
that's given that that critique of
corruption has warrant in some sense
it's not easy to differentiate and to
say no look guys you got to think this
through is that human institutions
aren't perfect and you have to be awake
all the time to make sure they don't
degenerate entirely but that doesn't
mean that they're fundamentally corrupt
you know which is the claim for example
that America was predicated on the uh on
on a positive view towards slavery it's
like well obviously when America was
founded
slavery was thriving
and so there was this pro-slavery ethos
that was part and parcel of the American
project at that point but the
fundamental Drive of the system and all
of the Traditions upon which it was
founded was that all men are created
equal men and women are created equal
before God and that was the
principle that eventually won out and
it's hard to teach young people I think
to separate the wheat from the chaff
when it's so easy just to throw
everything out especially if there's no
immediate consequences especially when
you're lauded for doing so and all your
idiot teachers are telling you that's
the right thing to do
while today's cups of coffee often come
with hints of soy and social justice our
new coffee sponsor delivers an entirely
different experience it's bold strong
delicious and overall as good as the
causes it supports I'm speaking of
course about Black Rifle coffee many of
you know about Black Rifle already it's
a veteran founded and operated Coffee
Company who have made it their mission
to hire 10 000 veterans and they're well
on their way
by purchasing for Black Rifle Coffee
Company you're directly supporting the
military service Community but what
about the coffee itself well it's bold
strong and really good
go to Black riflecoffee.com and use
promo code Jordan for 10 off your first
order or when you sign up for a new
coffee Club subscription the
subscription gives you free shipping on
all coffee Club orders Early Access to
Club deals and promotions and special
discounts from their partner brands
that's black riflecoffee.com with promo
code Jordan for 10 off your first order
or when you sign up to become a coffee
Club member Black Rifle coffee
supporting veterans and America's coffee
right agreed
um look the the reason that I
um that I bothered with the historical
chapters in in the conservatism book is
is because I I think there's a a
um
a widespread misunderstanding about
about conservative thinkers about
Fortescue and Selden and Burke and and
and for that matter you know Washington
and Adams and Hamilton there's kind of
this assumption that if you're
Conservative then you you just think
that whatever exists is fine and it
doesn't need to be repaired when you
actually read these sophisticated
conservative thinkers what you find is
that none of them think this the the the
actual view is uh something much more
like what you were describing that
there's corruption in everything but
more than that
um every good system decays every good
system runs down this is a an integral
part you just you just see this over and
over again in anglo-american
conservative uh uh thinkers is every
system runs down every system decays and
that's just that's just the way human
societies are so the the principal job
of the conservative is not to to hold on
tight to whatever exists it's to look
for uh restoration it's to identify what
has become corrupt and decayed and to uh
look for a model either uh earlier in
history or sometimes even just you know
uh looking at the neighbors the way that
you know the pole that during the Polish
Revolution they they they they they
looked to to the British constitution
for for for a model and so the word
restoration it's a lot like the word
repentance it's a restoration is kind of
a is kind of a national political
repentance where where you look at
something and you say look this is
decayed we've gone off course
um or or there is an inherited evil that
you know can no longer be tolerated and
we have to fix it and the conservative's
job is to find a way to uh to to make
that repair what while strengthening the
entire system as a whole so I mean the
the example of slavery I think is is uh
it's on always on a lot of people's
minds and I think for good reasons but
important to notice that that uh that
the uh that Britain succeeded in
eliminating slavery on the basis of the
common law in the 1770s with without a
revolution without a civil war
um and the uh what what what what
happened is that uh Lord Mansfield
um looked at the you know the
integration of the Mercantile law over
the previous Century into the common law
and in a lot of ways that was very good
that's what made it made it possible for
you know for for Britain in in a lot of
ways to become a a a a a modern economy
but
um the the the idea that that uh human
beings could be bought and sold as
slaves was imported into the common law
by the Mercantile law less than you know
at the end of the 1600s and at a certain
point the uh the uh the the jurists the
the judges in Britain looked at this and
said we what's happening is we are
corrupting ourselves we're corrupting
our tradition by allowing this
institution of Slavery to to to be
brought into our country and they
limited it on the basis of of British
tradition the the English tradition they
said English common law does not does
not uphold slavery a person who is
enslaved in in England is always
enslaved unfairly now the interesting
thing is that the Americans uh an
important part of the Federalist party's
platform during the American Revolution
was the um uh the the uh bringing the
English common law uh in as as the the
uh the law of the new national federal
government
uh Jefferson opposed it Madison opposed
it but the Federalist Party the
conservatives they thought that they
needed this they they needed this common
law inheritance and and America in fact
does does still have that common law
inheritance until this day now
why is it that
um that if the English could get rid of
slavery you know without this abstract
declaration that you know that that on
all men are created equal why is it that
the Americans couldn't do it and I I I
think part of this is an optical
illusion I think I I think that the
Americans could have done it but
um the the uh the strength of liberalism
in in America's founding and and you
know going forward uh comes from the
fact that while uh uh Washington and his
party were genuine conservatives the the
American Constitution of 1787 is
basically it in in many respects the
restoration of the of the British
constitution that's what Washington and
his party stood for Jefferson and his
party Tom Payne
um the these really were Enlightenment
liberal radicals and and uh Jefferson is
famous for saying things like uh
repeatedly uh that one generation is a
foreign country to to to the preceding
Generations meaning that that each
generation owes nothing to the past each
generation receives nothing from the
past that that can't be simply
overthrown and revised and I I think
this brings us to you know to the heart
of uh of what we're facing today you
know I I just read a very I just read a
very interesting scientific paper that's
oddly relevant to this it's really
revolutionary I think it was published
in nature
and uh
it showed no there's this idea that's
common currency among evolutionary
biologists that mutations are entirely
random
and this turns out not to exactly be
true
and so there's a hierarchy of genetic
stability
and the older the genes are
that code for the properties of a given
organism
the more likely those genes are to be
restored to their original condition if
a mutation does occur by DNA repair
mechanisms
right so so the reason I think this is
so relevant is you imagine that our
the presumptions that make up our
society and stabilize them have a
hierarchical structure and some of them
are old and deep and one of the oldest
and deepest would be the idea that men
and women alike are made in the image of
God
and so that's a very fundamental
proposition
and then you might say that well the
more fundamental of proposition is the
more other propositions depend on it and
then you might say
it's those most fundamental propositions
that have to be transmitted from
generation to generation the more
peripheral propositions which are newer
and they would be akin to newer genetic
variations
in a given organism the more they're
free to vary because not so many things
depend on them and they should vary
because they their fundamental nature is
still up in the air in some sense but
there's a hierarchy of presumptions and
the deeper the presumption the less the
less it should be amenable to change
I think that can be worked out on the
conservative side
I I think so I I mean I I I think you're
describing exactly what I'm describing
just from another field yeah by the way
um there's this uh really fascinating
passage in in in Hayek in Friedrich
Hayek
um who you know that a great Economist
and and liberal thinker from the middle
of middle of the last century
um he he argues that there's a uh that
the emergence of the picture of science
as an evolutionary process by trial and
error is the is the transference of the
old common law idea of the law as
evolutionary the Constitution as
evolutionary the transfer of that was
completely natural you know for for uh
for English and Scottish thinkers who
who knew that that the law was
supposedly evolved this way to begin
thinking in the same way about science
as trial and error and and you know that
that that you know that that obviously
could easily have inspired uh Darwin as
well well then we we could think about
English common law the same way so
English common law
in tell me if I've got any of the
details of this wrong but basically
under the English system the presumption
is human beings have all the rights
there are intrinsically and then when
people come together and have a dispute
the dispute has to be adjudicated and
once it's adjudicated that becomes a
common law principle and then those
principles are supposed to be bound by
precedent and so then the
presuppositions in English common law
that have the most precedent are the
most fundamental and so it's an
incrementally transforming structure but
it but it's also hierarchically
structured and it differs from let's say
the French civil code it certainly
differs from systems of thought like
Marxism which are all rational creations
and imposed from the top down and so
English common law did have this
bottom-up nature which gives it well I
would say in some sense a preeminent
status among legal codes around the
world it's it's a remarkable it's a
remarkable body of work
yep it is let me just add I I think your
description is apt let me just just add
a couple of of points to that uh one of
them is that the the
um the common law is uh is a development
uh coming down the centuries of biblical
law if you go you know go back to the
the earliest formulations of legal codes
in in Britain
um a lot of it is taken literally
explicitly directly from uh from from
law codes in Hebrew scripture and a
second Point that's that's important is
that
um is that what you're describing the uh
the the jostling among individuals which
then create cases that's at precedence
um that also happens at the
Constitutional level not not only at the
at the at the level of individuals uh uh
competing with one another
um you know for for uh for rights but
also if you look at
um you look at Magna Carta and the
Petition of Right and the English Bill
of Rights and then after that the the
American Bill of Rights if if you look
at that as a uh as an ongoing
um uh jostling between between the
executive which you know originally the
king and the legislature which was
originally the Nobles and the uh what
you see is exactly this kind of uh trial
and error to find the right balance
which goes on for literally goes on for
for a thousand years and the the
Constitution that
um that the Americans in 1787 took upon
themselves if you if you compare it to
uh the earlier English Petition of Right
and Bill of Rights you'll see that
virtually all of the rights
that that appear in the American
Constitution are actually things that
were already worked out right right over
centuries in in in this trial and error
effort to find the right balance in
England
so so this means Jefferson is wrong
because he didn't in in the manner that
you described
um that each successive generation is a
foreign territory compared to the
previous because he's not taking into
account
the hierarchical nature hierarchical
nature of fundamental social
presuppositions
and so he might be correct On The Fringe
in the periphery but at the core he's
wrong and the case that you're making is
that while you have the American
constitutional axioms let's say
including
expanded to include the Bill of Rights
but that's grounded in English common
law that's a consequence of centuries of
trial and error
it's and it's it's not you know it's not
it's trial and error in a very
particular way because
imagine that you and I have a dispute
and we uh 300 years ago and we go in
front of an English Court the court has
to rule in relationship to the dispute
in a manner that's commensurate with all
previous rulings of that broad type
and then the rulings have to be
consistent enough with grounded human
intuitions of what constitutes a just
settlement so that when the settlement
is handed down the parties involved
actually find it acceptable enough not
to degenerate into murder
that's super well super well said I I
think that's exactly exactly the point
and if you if you now want to ask
um let's say that we we go with
Jefferson for a moment and we say
um actually you know using reason like
we can we we can just come up with what
what the right answer is in in in the
1700s we don't we don't need the you
know 800 years of of trial and error
before that if you go with Jefferson
where you end up is with a view that
says look I exercised reason I don't
need I I don't need tradition because I
can exercise reason I don't need an
inheritance of of ideas and principles
and and precedence because I can just
use reason if you go in that direction
what happens is that even though your
intentions are liberal and not Marxist
your your intention is just to allow
people to be free of previous
generations that's all to think for
themselves if you do that then what
whatever what you will come up with is
something that it it it it it it runs
down it actively aggressively runs down
the the inheritance of Common Sense and
precedence and intuitions that people
have have gotten well
what is this logic what is this this
reason that the Liberals are stressing
precisely I mean if you if you
investigate that from a psychological
perspective I mean you could think about
it as the application of pure logic but
that's foolish because people just
aren't that logical and very few people
are trained to think logically and any
case and then with regards to reason
itself unless you're a radical
empiricist and you believe that the
pathway forward and the guard rails are
self-evident as a consequence of
exposure to the facts which is naive
beyond belief then your reason is an
empty concept because I mean if we're
reasoning with language let's say
which which would be the most reasonable
way of reasoning because you can
communicate with other people that way
every single bloody word you use was
crafted by other people every phrase has
a history every sentence is a fragment
of a philosophical tradition and then
every profound idea is very unlikely to
be original and so the very tools of
Reason itself are established by not
only by tradition but by a an
unbelievably profound hierarchical
consensus because you and I couldn't
even speak unless almost everything we
said to each other was comprehensible
because of our shared set of assumptions
again we can play on the fringes right I
mean as long as we're 99 in agreement we
can talk about the one percent where we
differ and we can nibble away at the
edges but if we were radically different
in our orientation and our individual
reason we couldn't even talk
right
by the way this point is um already made
explicitly by uh by Selden in uh John
Selden the the the great common lawyer
and constitutional scholar
um in in in the early 1600s that that
every single word that we use is
something that was crafted by previous
generations and that's the basis uh for
for our capacity to to to be able to
live together now the to go back to your
uh uh a question that you you started
with if
you have a society that has a common
inheritance okay and I'm not saying that
everybody has to agree on everything but
there is exactly as you said there's a
an inheritance in which 90 or 95 or 98
of of of of what we think has been
inherited and we agree on it and then we
argue you know as you say on the fringes
that's a that is a very good description
of a successful cohesive uh uh polity in
which their competing parties in in
which there are you know you can have
them Democratic votes you can have
transitions from the rule of one party
to another but all of this depends on a
a mutual recognition among the different
parties that they're part of one
inheritance and that they're willing to
honor one another because even though
they disagree they may hate each other
but but they understand that that
they're part of
one structure as you said one one
inherited logic and what we've done
today is to say no we don't need any of
that yeah we don't need any of that it
doesn't it doesn't matter how much of it
you you uproot and throw out because we
trust the the new human reason that the
revolutionaries are going to come up
with to be something that better than
what we inherited well I think I think
you really see this I really believe
that you see the most egregious example
of this
in our
willingness to redefine the meaning of
man and woman
because
I my psychological Studies have led me
to the presumption that
there might not be any more fundamental
perceptual category than
man and woman then male and female
and there's the direct perception of
that on the biological front which is a
precondition for successful reproduction
we should point out in case it has to be
pointed out and then there are symbolic
Echoes of masculine and feminine that
pervade almost everything we
conceptualize so you see that echoed for
example in the Taoist conception of
reality as yin and yang which is a
masculine and feminine dichotomy
there's this bipolarity of cognition
that has as its fundamental basis the
distinction between the Sexes and you
know when when Canada moved in 2016 to
Force
the Reconstruction of pronouns onto uh
unsuspecting population in the name of
compassionate narcissism I thought well
because this is such a fundamental
cognitive category
if we introduce entropy into it if we
introduce disorder then we're going to
destabilize those who are already quite
disordered and the most likely to be
destabilized in that manner would be
adolescent girls because that there's
historical precedent for that
and so this idiot insistence that all
conceptions are up for grabs belies the
fact that there's a hierarchy of
perception
in in relationship to the different
degrees of depths of different
perceptions and it replaces hierarchical
order not with the freedom that's
promised by the marxists and the
Liberals but with absolute bloody
intolerable chaos
and when we I do believe that we're in a
Tower of Babel situation in a real sense
is that we become intellectually
pretentious beyond belief we're building
scaffolds that are in principle designed
to replace God and now we've reached uh
impasse where we no longer speak the
same language we can't even decide what
constitutes a man and what constitutes a
woman and if you can't agree on that
then I don't think there's anything that
you can agree on
and and so if you ask you know
what does the individual
man or woman today facing uh the the
this this the the uh um this permanent
cultural revolution which is uprooting
the most fundamental things that have
been inherited the most fundamental
concepts that we we use to understand
reality are being smashed so where do
they turn and here I you know I I
understand that this could be
controversial for all sorts of people
but I I I I think the bottom line is
that a that if you see the Revolution
coming you understand it's going to
destroy everything you understand
there's there's going to literally be
nothing that is not uprooted
if you see this what's the force that
that could stop it well the force that
could stop it is is fundamentally
um young men and young women young
families older older men and older women
find going to to to to that institution
which continues to hand down Traditions
intact which is in our society is almost
only at this point uh the church the the
Orthodox Churches I Orthodox I'm I'm
theological traditionally whether
they're right whether they're Catholic
or Protestant or or Orthodox doctrinally
uh or or the synagogue or some other
traditional community in which a life of
conservation and transmission is
actually taking place it it you know it
it begins with
um young people saying look I need to be
part of I need to be part of a community
but the next step is to say it can't
just be you know any arbitrary Community
it can't be you know like like uh a
bunch of 18 year olds uh in a dorm room
we're going to set up a community
because because they're not they're not
actually that's a gang not a
conservative
right they're not they're not engaged in
conserving and transmitting anything all
right and so the only way that you can
plug yourself into uh this the the the
chain of conservation and transmission
which has been lost is to find older
people to find older people who've seen
it done I mean you're not you're not
going to be able to keep a marriage
together if you don't have actual living
models of older people who have
succeeded in keeping a marriage together
so you can see what it's like so that
you can you can pick it up from them and
the same thing is true for for
everything else
if you want to save yourself right I
mean I I think this is true nationally
also but at the moment if you as an
individual you want to save yourself now
I'm not I'm not talking about the
Christian question about like your
Eternal salvation I I I'm I'm Jewish I'm
talking about you want to save yourself
in this life in this world all right and
then what you're going to have to do is
you're going to have to I I know this is
difficult but you're going to have to go
to older people who have a functioning
congregation and say look I'm coming
here to learn I'm not coming here to
judge you I'm not coming here to you
know to preach the things I believe I'm
coming here to learn how a life of
conservation and transmission used to
work I I want to learn that to see
whether I can be part of it right that
is a very big change the best way to
fight the onco oncoming Revolution is as
you say the on coming chaos is with
order and that but but you can't create
that order yourself you you have to be a
part of some existing order and luckily
it still exists so in relationship to
your comments earlier about the
conservatives thinkers who I think we
should also go through by the way
making the case that things did fall
apart of their own accord there's a
a thinker Virginia eliada great
historian of religions who tracked the
commonalities among flood myths across
very many different cultures and came up
with a formula for Why God or the gods
would become angry enough to
destroy everything in a in a in a
chaotic
catastrophe
and he said well the first issue is that
things deteriorate of their own accord
and that's just an observation about the
effect of entropy I would say is that
Things Fall Apart if you just leave them
sit they'll fall apart by themselves
because things Decay and then eliad also
said that
a very common theme was that that
process of entropic Decay was sped Along
by the sins of men
and what he meant by that was the
proclivity for people to be willfully
blind
and so imagine that there are small
things going wrong in your marriage your
wife becomes less attentive or you do
your attention starts to be attracted by
other people and you just let it slide
you know that something's up but you
don't do the attentive work necessary to
do the repairs when the time is
appropriate
well then
you speed the process of decay
and so one of the implications of this
was that
the central organizing principle of the
psyche and this might be the principle
to which religious systems
to some degree
put forward as the highest possible good
is something like constant attention to
that process of Decay and communication
about it to stem off the ravages of time
you could think about that as an
organizing principle of the psyche a
necessary organizing principle of the
psyche so the god Horus for example in
the ancient Egyptian Pantheon
was the All-Seeing Eye
that paid attention and who could see
corruption when it emerged and the
Mesopotamian God Marduk was had eyes all
the way around his head and spoke magic
words
and so that seemed to be something like
a core organizing principle and you
talked about these
these Cardinal canonical conservative
thinkers
um and their willingness to make the
presumption that things did go wrong and
needed to be fixed maybe we could go
through them a little bit if you don't
mind
Fortescue hooker Selden and Burke and
well you know before before we launch
into them let me let me just say
something about um about the the
biblical uh flood myth and it's uh uh
flood story I should say and its
relationship uh to the conversation that
we're that we're having the
um
eliada's uh mapping is helpful but there
is a big difference between uh between
the Mesopotamian flood myth uh where you
have basically the gods get angry
because human beings are annoying human
beings are bothering them they're
they're Troublesome right when when that
story in that story in in you know in in
the hands of uh of of
Moses and the Israelite prophets that
story
becomes one of
um of God's intention of creating you
know a an edenic World a a perfect world
where where human beings and animals
um are are all eating grasses and
vegetables and no you know no creature
hurts another creature and the what you
see in the biblical account is that uh
that the world is in has this intrinsic
the the the chaotic Waters that God's
God's wind or God's spirit is Fashions
the world out of those chaotic Waters
never you know they never fully go away
they're all always constantly about to
happen and and that affects uh human
nature in that human beings are
incapable of living in this perfect
world that you know that God imagined uh
in in in Eden the flood story actually
um has almost the you know the the
opposite meaning because what what God
discovers from the flood is that he
thought that he was going to give Noah
and and know his children a you know a
chance to create the perfect world the
moment that that the flood is over and
Noah starts getting drunk there's sexual
impropriety there's also the you know
there's all sorts of awful things that
immediately happen to Noah who was
supposed to be the best of you know the
best of of human beings
and that creates a a religious framework
in which God says all right I can't
perfect the world I have no way of
perfecting the world it's not within my
power to do that which is
not exactly the way that it's often
presented but that's what it says in the
text is that God doesn't have the power
to create a perfect world and he needs
human beings to take up a a role as his
you know his vice Regents as his uh uh
Associates and assistants in in trying
to fix in trying to fix the world and
that structure notice that it's a
hierarchical structure it's it's it's
not a metaphor of an all-powerful God
that we should just obey it's a
different metaphor it's a metaphor of a
a God who actually needs our help he
could destroy the whole world but he
can't fix it without our help that's the
fundamental structure that makes Judaism
and later Christianity different from
the preceding religions is that there is
a role for man within the hierarchy of
the cosmos God needs us and the the
Covenant is about us stepping forward
and shoulder shouldering that
responsibility
and an economy as volatile as this one
it's important to have control when
you're making a big purchase like a new
car that's where cars in comes into play
carsing is completely changing the way
you buy a car online an online car
shopping website with millions of listed
Vehicles carzing works with over 25 000
dealers Nationwide to help you find your
dream car by partnering with Credit
Agencies lenders and dealerships karzing
provides you with everything you need
before stepping foot into a dealership
their mission is to make auto financing
quick and easy while providing a modern
hassle-free way of shopping for cars
their Innovative technology and
financial tools provide consumers with
the ability to instantly pre-qualify
online without affecting your credit
score plus you can search for vehicles
with instant financing details including
down payment monthly payment term and
APR once you find your dream car at your
ideal budget all you have to do is bring
your save deal voucher with you to the
dealership to finalize your next ride
carsing offers transparency to the max
you know you're purchasing options
before you set foot into the dealership
which makes the whole process so much
more convenient visit carzing.com Jordan
today to skip the guesswork and find the
best deals near you that's karzing.com
Jordan
so the other thing that I've seen
another thing that I've seen on my tours
is that
the call to responsibility has become
somewhat of a Clarion call and you know
you can see the marxists and the
environment and the environmental types
as well
capitalizing on the attractiveness of
responsibility and Destiny to some
degree by offering these utopian schemes
as a
as a sort of Messianic alternative to
Adam the enemy of liberalism let's let's
put it that way the conservative
approach seems to me to be something
more like
um
what would you call it the pursuit of
responsibility in Humble micro domains
at least to begin with right so that
to say it yourself right you should try
to set your family relationships right
and maybe to establish a family and
having established a certain degree of
Harmony and functionality in your family
then maybe you could extend out a few
tentacles into the surrounding Civic
community and you could build from the
bottom up you could build a stable life
and a stable social life and then a
stable political life let's say from the
bottom up as a and it one of the things
that I've been heartened by is the fact
that if you lay out those arguments to
young people you say look you need to be
embedded in a social surround and you
need to take responsibility for it the
reason you need that is because that's
where you're going to find the purpose
of your life that sounds to me like an
echo of this biblical insistence that
there actually is something for human
beings to do as long as they don't bite
off more than they can chew and get all
prideful about it you you said maybe
maybe start a family so you know I this
might be controversial with some of some
some of your viewers but in in in the
Jewish version of the biblical tradition
in the Jewish tradition
the the starting a family is an
obligation that everyone who can do it
must do it right and if if if you if you
if you think about that in in terms of
the responsibility issue
young uh Orthodox Jews are raised to
believe that that if that if you don't
take on this responsibility if if you
you as a young man if you don't you
don't make it your business to to to
find a wife and to have children and to
uh to create a to to do what it takes to
to create a stable structure
you're going to be for your entire life
unable to understand what it actually
takes in order to create uh to create
human order I mean the the the the the
the the the you know the the various
people have noticed that the European
that that many of the European leaders
uh are are unmarried and don't have
children
um and the uh the the
the situation in which
um
young people don't learn how to they
they don't learn how to govern they
don't learn how to uh to be a king and a
queen in their own homes they don't know
how to govern a family they don't know
how to how to hold it together uh
despite the you know the incredible pain
and difficulties that that that that
often takes place uh between men and
women and and uh and children aren't you
know children are you know they're
sometimes fun but they're sometimes
incredibly difficult incredibly painful
to raise this this whole concept that
every every young man and woman who can
do it
must take the responsibility to bring
life into the world to create the world
in you to try to build up on the basis
of what's been inherited to try to make
it better than what it was in in
previous generations that that view I I
think in in many ways that's like the
the Bedrock
um Jewish and Christian view which says
you know we're not slave we're not
slaves to the gods we're we're Partners
in creating this world but that that
means we have an obligation to do the
act of creation and the the most
fundamental Act of Creation is creating
a family once you've done that then you
know you you were hinting to this that
then I think you can also learn to
create congregations to uphold uh
Nations all of that flows from the first
step of very young people taking
responsibility for creating you know
basically their own little world in a
family while there is no more profound
responsibility than that and so it's an
initiation into profound responsibility
I mean one of the things that happens to
a parent
that and I think it's very difficult for
this to happen if you don't become a
parent is that once you're a parent
there is definitely someone
in your life who's more important than
you are
right so your your orientation to the
world well I would say it matures
properly and it matures under the force
of moral obligation fundamentally you
have this person now who's
for better worse almost entirely
dependent on your not so Tender Mercies
you and your wife and whose subject to
all of your
trials and tribulations and inadequacies
and
if you have any sense at all that wakes
you up as much as anything will and
without that I think it's very difficult
to
shed the
constraints of hedonistic adolescence
that's not good for me just you know
it's not good for people if you just go
so go ahead
yeah no I I I think that's exactly true
I think I I as you said you you can't
you can't in a lot of ways you can't
actually mature uh until you've created
and are the the government the uh of a
household and the alternative that that
uh that sort of mainstream liberalism
gives us this uh that that this view
that you know when when you reach 18 or
20 years old you're a your rational
individual and you know now you can do
whatever you want you can and usually
doing whatever you want we can see in
young people that doing whatever you
want means that they get too scared to
get married they get too scared to have
children they the the the even I'm
talking about something that even
affects even affects Orthodox religious
communities you can see it very very
clearly that that the um uh
that they look at at these
responsibilities as a kind of uh with
with terrible fear as though it's like a
like an enslavement something something
they need they need to spend another
five years and another ten years and
another five years get more degrees
right you know they need to keep
preparing in order to be ready to do it
and
that that's the the opposite of the
traditional view that says that says
take the responsibility and and then
live up to it you'll grow by living up
to it you'll become a complete person as
the rabbis say you complete Yourself by
entering and taking the responsibility
of marriage and children and the the
alternative of is is
adolescence that's extended forever what
you think that when you're that when
you're 35 years old and uh and and now
you're gonna start looking to get
married it's going to be easier to get
married you you'll you'll actually be
more capable of it than you were when
you were 23 I I don't I don't think
that's true at all I I think what you
learned during those extra 10 or 15
years of adolescence is is to to just
care for yourself instead of to learn
how to create something to learn
something that idea also highlights in
some sense both the Practical necessity
and the inevitability of
Faith or or the lack thereof I mean many
things in your life
you have to throw yourself into without
first knowing that you can do it and I I
don't mean to do that in an impulsive
and foolish manner like heedless of all
risks I mean that
when you get married
you don't know if it's going to work and
in some sense that's even a foolish
question because the issue is that when
you decide to get married
it's the first and foremost decision
among 50 000 decisions that are going to
determine whether or not you can stay
married
and you can boil that down to a question
like did I marry the right person and
the answer to that is always no and they
didn't marry the right person either and
because neither of you are the right
person in your current unbelievably
flawed condition
and so but you throw yourself into it
thinking that having faith that you can
manage it and also having faith that the
alternative that no matter how dismal
the reality the alternative is likely to
be far worse and I would say the same
thing is true on the child rearing front
which is
as you pointed out it's difficult it
isn't obvious that you're prepared or
that extra preparation is really going
to help you
but
what's the alternative to the difficulty
one of the things I love about the story
of Abraham one of the things I think
that makes it such a profound story is
that
Abraham is really characterized by quite
the protracted adolescence according to
the beginning of the story he's quite
old when God finally convinces him to
get the hell out of his tent and to get
out there in the world and God in that
story is definitely manifested manifests
himself as the Call to Adventure
even to the pathologically
underdeveloped The Call to Adventure and
of course Abraham just steps into any
number of catastrophes as soon as he
leaves the confines of his tantanas and
his father's home but the story is a
Triumph in its totality because despite
the fact that he encounters tyranny and
the likely loss of his wife at the hands
of
people who are essentially tyrants and
starvation and War and all of the
catastrophes of life he has a great
adventure and that's the adventure as
far as I can tell it's something like
the adventure of Truth and dedication
and responsibility and that's very
seldom marketed you know by
conservatives to young people as an
adventure
right and you said their default
position is often to regard these
strictures of community as
what would you call it impediments and
impositions on their hedonic freedom but
there's very little of value in that
hedonic freedom and all of the adventure
in life as far as I can tell is to be
found weirdly enough in truth and
responsibility yep I I I I I completely
agree you you have
um uh
you have God telling Abraham
look I I I I'm I'm gonna give you an
opportunity uh to become a great nation
to uh become a a a great tradition to
become to become a a teacher of all the
peoples in the world but you know that's
the biggest adventure that you know that
the prophets could imagine was setting
out to become a teacher to the entire
world and to and to create a great
nation that would influence the whole
world and and and and and and and and
would be in Covenant with God they the
prophets can't imagine a larger scale
Adventure than that and yet the whole
thing
pivots around
you take a wife you have to have a child
you have to raise that child that that
involves hardship that involves
difficulty and you know there's all of
these descriptions of Abraham's
adventures and and you know it it takes
many generations until you can see the
consequences of what of of of you know
the full consequences of what he did
but the first step is taking
responsibility as you say and now we
have to ask we have to I mean now we're
talking about you know tens of millions
of young people and not so young people
who are beginning to realize that you
know that that a career meaning you know
like
your place within the corporate economy
you're you know which cubicle getting to
that corner office that that's nowhere
near the adventure of
cre creating a family which is creating
a little nation which then has the
opportunity to grow if you do it right I
mean really these two things are
basically
um battling with one another uh which of
them is more important and the the the
the answer will you know you can have
both sometimes it's true but but it's
it's terribly misleading it's terribly
misleading because because that cubicle
in which you know you sit in front of
that computer computer screen and try to
you know move yourself up in the in in
in the the corporate game that that's
not a life of conservation and
transmission that's not a life of
responsibility that you know that
it for most people it's almost nothing
actually and and and so
what we really need to be telling people
is
um is look enough enough with the fear
enough with the fear cut come come join
a a religious community a congregation
in which people did get married when
they were young and they did have
children and and and and and come see
what it's like but by the way the uh the
uh the the Commandment of of uh uh being
fruitful and having children is is only
one part of your place in the hierarchy
the another part of your place in the
hierarchy is the commandment to honor
honor your parents and and that also is
something that young people find
incredibly difficult whenever I speak in
front of young audiences the moment that
I mention the moment that I mention you
know honoring your father and your
mother honoring your teachers the
immediately somebody says well you know
only if they deserve to be honored right
I mean you're not talking about honoring
them you know if if they're terrible and
of course that loophole basically allows
you know everything single individual
young man and woman in the audience to
say well you know my parents are you
know I judge my parents they're not you
know they're not not worthy of being
honored that it it begins by going away
to college and you don't need to talk to
them anymore and it ends by putting your
parents in an old age home uh and paying
somebody else to take care of them in
old age again you know just simply
dumping responsibility on somebody else
paying somebody else to take the
responsibility and and both parts of
this the the fear of bringing children
in the world but also the refusal the
refusal to admit the biblical truth that
you have a lifelong obligation to honor
your parents your father and your mother
you don't choose whether to have that
obligation or not this is like you know
it this is this this is both barrels
against the fundamental Assumption of
liberalism which is that you you choose
your obligations but you don't choose
your obligations you don't choose which
family you're born into you you you you
don't choose who your parents are or who
your brothers are or who are your
sisters are you don't even choose where
your children are and so all of these in
the end are are unchosen obligations and
the the question is you know are you
strong are are you going to develop the
strength of personality the the power
and the wisdom and and and and and and
the ability to uphold these
responsibilities in a way that's
impressive and classy and and and
powerful and and it can also be
magnificent you know you you get to a
certain age and and you've got
um you know all of these Decades of of
um you know I think I think of my you
know my my aunt and uncle uh who who uh
uh they're in their 80s now and uh
Orthodox Jews in Israel and they uh uh
they took a a um a a a drone photograph
of them with the you know 90 of their uh
their biological and adopted descendants
who came to like a picnic and you look
you look at this and you say you know
they they they they built an Empire they
I mean they've begun to you know to
alter the face of the world with what
what they did what about you are you
know you're just gonna sit it out though
that honor too you know I've been
thinking about
many of the
injunctions on the religious side as
moral efforts
so faith for example
you can pillory it as blind insistence
that something that no one could
possibly believe to be true is true or
you could say
no faith is the courage that it requires
to LEAP into the unknown and to wrestle
with possibility itself
and you could think of honor the same
way is that you know I read this book by
Frank McCourt called Angela's Ashes and
in that book he talks about his father
back in Ireland they were very poor
Irish family
and uh his father was a absolutely
unrepentant alcoholic who drank up every
cent the family ever made and had many
many children
number of whom developed very serious
illnesses as a consequence of the
poverty induced by the father's drinking
and some of whom died
and Frank
had the wisdom even as a young man to
sort of divide his father into two parts
there was sober useful productive
encouraging morning Father and then
there was night time in binge father and
he did everything he could to extract
out the encouraging patriarchal Spirit
from the best that his father had to
offer and it seems to me that that's
something like honor
you know and to honor your parents to
honor your wife to honor your siblings
is to
is to have the best in you serve the
best in them it's something like that
it's active right it's it's it it
requires effort like courage requires
effort
it's it's not something you do blindly
and foolishly and so when people say
well my parents have done things that
make them less than honorable in my eyes
I mean there's two rejoinders to that
the first is well and what makes you so
perfect
and so who exactly is it
within you that's doing this judging
and second
you have an obligation to work as hard
as you can to
Foster the best in other people and that
would include your parents and your
siblings and the people that you were
close to that's something you really
work out and that's the honoring
you know when my wife and I got married
to speak personally for a a bit one of
the things we did decide was that
we were going to
honor each other as husband and wife and
so
we try
very hard for example not to put each
other down particularly in public and
not and that wasn't because we weren't
often irritated with one another because
obviously if you live with someone
irritation emerges it's because you have
a duty
to honor your wife or your husband
and if you don't uphold that Duty then
you denigrate the relationship and you
make yourself look like an utter fool
too
you know if you don't treat your wife
with a certain amount of respect well
first of all
it it it does her no good but it also
does no you no good you entered into the
relationship
you have a moral obligation to
keep it as pristine as you can in your
public utterances
and that's part of the necessary
responsibility that provides a scaffold
for the relationship
same with your parents
yeah I I I I I would add that it's not
just the public utterances I mean you
know there's everybody at this point has
you know the the these Hollywood images
of uh you know of uh uh Happy marriages
with you know which just sort of like
magically everybody's having a good time
and unhappy marriages where people are
are are are you know are are are are are
constantly insulting and abusing one
another and what what what is missing
from you know this simplified version of
marriage is that
you know you you simply don't have to
say everything you think all the time
and part of
um an integral part of uh liberalism is
the you know I want to express myself I
you know I I feel something so I want to
say it I want to tell people with with
the the Assumption being that that if
you say everything you think then you
know then you'll persuade the other you
know your your your wife or your parents
your persuade the world of you know the
truth of your view but you know
empirically we say you know we can see
that's that that isn't remotely true if
you say everything you think all the
time
um then what happens is that that you
hurt your wife over and over and over
again and you bring her to the point
where she you know even the things that
she could do you know that you wanted to
do she she finds painful she starts
hurting you back I mean the the the the
the whole traditional view that honoring
means sometimes you don't say the truth
okay I'm not saying that you you know
you should lie to your wife or or your
husband God forbid I'm not talking about
that but I'm I I'm saying that that for
every 10 criticisms that you know come
to you of you know about your wife
it might be that only one of them is
worth saying and that one maybe
shouldn't be worth saying it shouldn't
be said now maybe it should be said
later well there's actually he said you
know no there's empirical data on that
so if you track the utterances of
married couples and then you use
foreign
the utterance tracking to predict the
longevity of the relationship
it was found that
if the relationship deteriorates to the
point where there's one negative comment
for every five positive comments then
the relationship doesn't maintain itself
so twenty percent negative is too high
but interestingly enough
there's a bound on the other end too
which is that if the positive to the
negative exceeds 11 to 1 the
relationship also tends to deteriorate
and so it's something like judicious
communication right you don't have to
make a case that every time something
irritates you that turns into a war
but you can't be a pushover or a
or someone who is naively blind and
expect the relationship to maintain
itself as well so that this is you know
this is actually one of the the central
arguments that uh that I make in in my
conservatism book which is that honoring
which which is purposely trying to the
the the uh in in Hebrew the word is for
for honoring the word is to literally
make someone heavy to to you know like
uh
um in English we can we can say uh uh
the the certain statements or certain
words were uh were significant uh here
we're talking about
um uh making an individual significant
by by making them waiting giving giving
weight to their words saying it was
important that you did that it was good
that you did that this is actually the
key to creating a loyal relationship
people feel people don't feel loved if
they're not being honored people don't
feel good if they're not being honored
they if they're not being honored they
they they begin to hate they begin to
resent and
so you can say this with respect to to
husbands and wives you can say this with
respect to children's children relating
to their parents but you can also I mean
take a look politically at you know what
it what's happening in America what's
happening in other Democratic countries
where where the uh the competing
political parties the competing tribes
no longer honor one another right and
you know all you need all you need to do
is to you know go back to the uh you
know to to to the the Nixon Kennedy
Kennedy debates from the 1960s or the
the the the rate Reagan uh Reagan
Mondale debates from the 80s and just
look look at those videos of the way
they treat one another I mean it may be
that in their hearts they hate one
another and they think they're they're
dangerous people but look at the way
they talk they they they're constantly
giving honor to the other side because
they they they value the fact that that
if the other side wins then they're
going to be the loyal opposition they'll
do their best to honor them until the
next election hopefully they'll win I
don't want to turn this into something
like you know two two I uh uh um dreamy
or utopian but the difference between
you know what that kind of politics and
the politics we have today which
consists you know of this constant
constant drumbeat of insult abuse
slander dishonoring one another look
it's just like a marriage if you want a
divorce if you want a civil war then
just keep dishonoring the other person
just keep focusing on everything that's
wrong with them and you'll you'll you'll
get your divorce you'll get your Civil
War so you're construing honor as
something like respect and encouragement
I mean one of the things that BF Skinner
who was famously able to train animals
to do almost anything
he pointed out that the most effective
behavior modification technique to put
it rather coldly was the use of targeted
reward and so he would watch animals and
when they did something that was
approximately
appropriate to what he was trying to
teach them to do he would reward them
and so for example if he wanted to have
a rat
walk up a little ladder and do a dance
on the top he just watched the route
until it got close to the ladder and
when it got close to the ladder in its
cage he'd give it a food pellet and then
it would hang around the ladder more and
then eventually it would put a pop on
one of the rungs and he'd give it a food
pellet and soon he could get the route
climbing the ladder and doing a little
dance on top and all sorts of
complicated things and he knew he knew
that you could shape Behavior with
threat and punishment but that reward
was much more
effective although it required of a
large degree of attention one of the
things I suggested to my clinical
clients and in my lectures was that
you pay very close attention to the
people around you
and whenever they do something that you
like to see them repeat
you let them know in some detail what it
was that you observed and that sounds
like the manner in which you're
construing honor in addition to the
respect element which is to give credit
where credit is due yeah this is this is
this is not simply give credit where
credit is due because uh you know as we
said before
um if you're if your mindset is you know
I'm judging I'm critiquing then you'll
easily destroy I mean you'll you'll just
destroy your your parents worthiness in
your own eyes your wife's worthiness and
your own you'll just your political
Rivals worthiness in your if that's what
you're doing you're saying well I'm
going to judge where it's due all the
time you're not you're not going to make
it you're you're not going to succeed in
in doing the action the biblical action
of giving honor the biblical action of
giving honor is it is uh
it is to elevate someone to make them to
to make them feel like they are
important and worthy not for you to
judge whether they're worthy for you to
make them feel that they are worthy and
the I mean I I the the the uh the
comparison with with the rats is useful
but in this case we have we have this
this is going taking place in both
directions between a husband and wife if
each of them
if if I tell my wife why she's Worthy
but she she comes away feeling loved and
strengthened and important and if she
does it back to me then I come away
feeling loved and strengthened and
important and and and and guess what the
the the the the single relationship that
Bond
is is when it's strengthened from both
sides in that way it it it becomes
something astonishing I mean even you
know the the whole thing about why you
know I don't feel attracted to my wife
you know of course you don't feel
attracted to your wife because because
you know you you were uh uh you you were
you were a young person and you're in
the the the the throes of uh hormonal
ecstasy and that lasts for a few years
but the the key to an attraction is if
if you keep making her feel worthy then
she'll continue to feel attracted to you
and if she keeps making you feel worthy
then you'll keep feeling attracted to
her there's a there's a direct
connection between honoring somebody and
and and they're feeling a desire for you
and I I'm I'm including physical desire
all kinds of desire and you know all of
these things are are
um kind of Secrets of the traditional
society which then
wipe wiped Away by the you know along
with the biblical tradition the the you
know the assumption that we don't have
anything learned to learn from scripture
or or or from tradition basically is the
key to our inability to to maintain
long-term any kind of loyalty so if you
were going to extract out a message
to young people and perhaps not just
young people who are watching and
listening from your work in relationship
to how they should conduct their life I
mean we've been touching on that the
entire conversation
um what what would you tell them in
relationship to conservatism rather than
liberalism or
or God forbid let's say Marxism why tilt
in the conservative direction if you're
young the most important thing about
tilting in a conservative direction is
that you yourself have to
have to lead a conservative life right
I'm I mean there's importance in voting
for conservatives but this is this is
not the key to the to the issue the key
to the issue is if you're voting for
conservatives but you're leading a
liberal life you're you know you're 33
years old and you're living with a you
know you're living with a woman year
after year you go to the beach on the
Sabbath you're not a member of any
congregation you you don't read
scripture you're a thousand miles away
from your parents so you don't you don't
inherit anything from from the community
that you grew up in because you don't go
to a congregation you don't have a new
community that you inherit from you talk
to your parents you know uh on
Thanksgiving or I don't know once a
month this this whole construct is a
liberal life it is a life in which
nothing is conserved and nothing is
transmitted from one generation to the
next it doesn't make any difference how
you vote if your personal life is one
which you're not part of the chain of of
transmission in a hierarchical society
in which you learn to honor people who
you didn't necessarily choose and and
and and you you know as you get older
and you you uh uh you get wiser and you
you accomplish uh real things by
creating a family
um as as you get older you you yourself
become honored you yourself become
somebody's who's worthy of that kind of
Honor which means that you feel good
about your life
which there isn't any any other way to
do it other than than in this way I
believe right so it's not a political
issue fundamentally what you're putting
forward it's and it also seems to be
commensurate with this idea that
psychological well-being which is a weak
word it's it's it's it's it's it's
happiness in the more classical sense I
would say which had ties to Virtue is
something that's practiced locally
practice personally practiced within the
family practiced within the broader
community and so forth and all these
nested hierarchical structures
and that that
that's really the essence in some sense
of
conducting yourself in a sustainable and
traditional Manner and the utility of
that is that you actually get a full
life and maybe you can live in a some
degree of productive peace and harmony
with other people which you know is
probably preferable to horrible conflict
and War
all of that's true and in our current
moment I mean it it's always been true
but in our current moment you know with
with where the alternatives are are
deracinated liberalism or or a a Marxism
whose purpose is just you know really is
to destroy all of the inherited
structures and knowledge that that have
come to us from previous generations you
know I I just I I can't see it I can't
understand how young people or even old
people you know who's
um who whose kids went away to college
and never came back you know why why not
why not try a uh a conservative
congregation and
um and and and and and see whether that
can
uh give you the kind of flowering that
that you you know you're looking for but
you don't have any other way to get it I
I don't
I I think this is the best thing that
anyone can do to fight the cultural
revolution and the woke Madness
is to uh to to find a Christian or a a
Jewish or some other
um uh congregation in which you can be
ex experience inheriting and honoring
honoring and inheriting yourself and be
be a part of that that's
you know if if if people don't do that
um the the there there isn't there isn't
much of a future well that's a that's a
salutary place to draw this conversation
to a close I would say uh I'm going to
talk to for all those who are listening
and watching I'm I'm going to talk to Dr
hazoni for another half an hour on the
DW plus platform I use that time to
wander through
my my guest's biography I'm very
interested in what sets people on a
particular path and also interested in
sharing
what you might describe as
the wisdom of success with as many
people who are inclined to listen and
watch and so that'll happen on the daily
wire plus platform
in the meantime thank you to all of you
who are watching and listening your
attention is much appreciated and thank
you
Dr uramazoni for
speaking with me today and uh for
sharing your thoughts with
with the listening and watching audience
much appreciated sir
my pleasure thank you
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com